And then we'll get to the Q.
And.
A.
I think this,
this is the kind of thing that I'd like to shed light on in any possible lecture
series on marks.
So this is called any advice on effectively implementing what I learned into my
life.
I resonate with 12 rules so much when reading,
but struggle to remember it in my day to day life.
Well,
you're not alone.
That was Sam.
You're not alone in that,
Sam.
I mean,
first of all,
you got to figure out what your timeframe is.
You know,
um,
one of the truisms of clinical psychology is that slow and incremental
improvement is first of all,
normative in the best possible way,
in the most optimistic situation,
but also very powerful.
And so of course you struggled to remember it in your day to day life because
life is difficult and it's harder to do things the not to do them.
And it's harder to do them well than to do them badly.
You know?
And it's easy to sit around and be hopeless.
I don't mean it's emotionally easy because it's not,
but it's procedural,
easy to be useless.
And to fall back into your old habits and to not discipline yourself.
And it's a matter of continual practice,
slow continual practice.
And I think a good example of that is something like weightlifting.
You know,
if you start a weightlifting program,
which I would recommend by the way because it,
it's tremendously advantageous physically and cognitively,
you're not going to really see results for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow,
but you can get pretty decent results over a six month period and absolutely
stellar results over a couple of years.
And so you have to make sure your timeframe is right and not to be too hard on
yourself.
And I did mention the future authoring program,
um,
earlier.
And one of the things I would recommend too is if you're having a hard time
implementing your,
your decision,
say you're ethical decisions that you spend a bit more time thinking them
through and writing them down in the future authoring program is really helpful
for that.
That's why we designed it.
And so get your goal straight and continue to practice every day.
And if you're not succeeding,
then make your goal slightly smaller.
You want to,
you want to make your goals large enough so that they challenge you,
but small enough so that you have a reasonable probability of succeeding at them
on a day to day basis.
And then you have to also understand that if you fail on a given day,
I could,
let's say you're trying to quit smoking and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think,
oh my God,
now I've screwed it up.
I've,
I've not quitting anymore.
And you smoke a whole pack of cigarettes.
It's like,
well,
there's a couple of mistakes there.
And one is,
well,
just because you had a cigarette doesn't mean you failed.
It just means that you had a cigarette.
You can start stopping again the next day.
And the fact that you had one cigarette in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had before that.
And so you've got to be realistically humble.
You gotta be ambitious enough in your goals so that you're pursuing something
that you regard as truly meaningful and worthwhile.
You know,
and maybe you can judge that to some degree.
If you think about someone you love attempting the same thing and think about
how you would feel if they managed it.
And if you would feel good,
then that's probably a good,
um,
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself?
You,
so you want your goals to be of sufficient nobility so that you can live with
yourself properly if you're pursuing them,
but you want them to be small enough so that you have a reasonable probability
of implementing them.
And if your implementation,
okay,
it's good.
You can start again.
Maybe
we're back.
Yeah.
Okay guys.
Well,
that was interesting.
The software that I use on my camera crashed and then when I reopened it,
it told me I hadn't purchased it and wanted me to reenter the serial number,
which is quite the interesting experience.
So,
so I'm just getting my questions back up.
Um,
this three quarter person that you see here is Julian,
who's,
you know,
reasonably helpful about these sorts of things now.
And then
I've,
Al,
I've almost actually learned how to do this.
I tell you,
you do get slower technologically as you get older.
It's kind of annoying or maybe get just fed up with it more.
It's hard to tell.
I think you probably stupider and less patient,
and so then you justify your less pay your stupidity by just assuming that
you're less patient.
So anyways,
um,
we're back.
Thanks Julian.
Okay.